[Musica]
io mi occupo da 30 anni ormai di
sondaggi di opinione ricerche e sono più
che altro proiettato verso il cosiddetto
le cosiddette che cerca verso il
compressore di quello che sarà il futuro
quindi le previsioni chi vincerà le
elezioni quanto potrà costare un
prodotto quali sarà la soddisfazione
della nostra utenza per un prodotto un
servizio e cose di questo genere
ho notato che nel corso degli ultimi 15
anni precedenti non si è mossa una
foglia delle tecnologie nelle
metodologie che si utilizzavano nel
corso degli ultimi 15 anni invece è
cambiato molto sono intervenuti alle
neuroscienze sono intervenuti i nuovi
nuove tecniche statistiche ci sono tutta
una serie di nuovi approcci verso il
l'utente finale che può essere
consultato rispetto ai vari eventi
previsionali e quindi le cose si stanno
muovendo molto uno dei temi che mi sta
molto a cuore e che sto cercando di
sviluppare ultimamente quello delle
cosiddette intelligenza della folla
ma il tema fondamentale da cui volevo
partire ma è così evidente che la forma
intelligente cioè di per sé andando a
pensare nella nostra intuizione questo è
contro intuitivo la folla di per sé non
è intelligente è di per sé il una
persona che è coinvolta in una folle
assume un atteggiamento etero diretto fa
quello che dicono gli altri
o se no diciamo perde tutto il suo
spirito critico e assume quello della
maggioranza delle altre persone questo è
una cosa che per noi è assolutamente
evidente quando parliamo ad esempio del
mondo del web e di internet e dei social
network e bene voglio dare appunto degli
esempi ce ne sono a iosa però venne da
alcuni diciamo molto molto puntuali che
possono aiutarci a capire esattamente di
cosa stiamo parlando
questo adesso ve lo spiego ma insomma
forse lo devo spiegarlo questo è antonio
cassano è un giocatore di calcio di
serie a non è noto per le sue per le sue
noto solo per le sue doti calcistiche e
l'hanno così
intitolato questa questa news e antonio
ricercatore universitario di filosofia
classica costretto a migrare per
l'italia l'università è una vergogna
diamoci da fare teniamo i nostri
cervelli in italia e cosa del genere
questo è un
una news è comparsa su facebook che ha
avuto una valanga di di like e una
infinità di commenti a favore del
mantenimento dei cervelli del fatto che
bisogna contenerli in italia serve a
tutte cose giustissime però
completamente e decontestualizzate per
cassano non c'entra niente con tutto
questo
un'altra interessante questa qui questo
anche questo lo riconoscerete tutti
credo il leader dei doors e in questo
caso addirittura gli hanno scritto
questo a goran hadzic ha commesso più di
50 rapine nel nord est ma ogni volta che
venne presa poi rilasciato
basta mandiamoli a casa renzi vai a casa
e tutte queste cose perché che per cui
ha generato una valanga di laica ma la
cosa interessante è che voglio farvi
notare che poi alla fine hanno coinvolto
con politico i temi noto politico
italiano il quale sotto disse sì è una
vergogna vediamo di
il sistema che questa cosa è stata
quindi nessuno è immune dal problema di
quella che io in questo caso definisco
la stupidità dei greci cioè fatto per
cui una notizia che viene per il fatto
di essere pubblicate viene data per
scontata e come una notizia già
verificata
non si tratta delle ferite news ma di
quello che le news e generano un
altro aspetto ancora più interessante è
quello in cui togliamo le fotografie
perché le fotografie esa diciamo
inducono ad un atteggiamento emotivo
togliamo la fotografia e scriviamo una
notizia di per sé
vediamo come reagisce la gente a una
notizia completamente falsa e che
possono in qualsiasi momento verificare
come falsa questa che però vedere adesso
è particolarmente interessante perché
sono una decina d'anni che ciclicamente
compare sempre la stessa è sempre la
stessa a una valanga di like e di gente
che continua a a cliccarla ad
apprezzarla e da fare delle dei commenti
totalmente a sproposito
eccola qua ieri il senatore pubbliche
approvato con 257 a favore e 160 60 5
astenuti e vi prego di fare la somma dei
numeri che sono oltre i senatori della
repubblica italiana
tanto per dire penso che se un livello
un po elevato per alcuni ma per noi no
ha approvato il disegno di legge del
senatore si lega sono dieci anni che c'è
questo senatore ci venga nessuno si
prende la briga di andare a vedere che
senatore si regga non esiste sono dieci
anni che fa una strage di larga adesso
un po di meno però
hai sempre nella top list che prevede la
nascita del fondo perché parlamentari in
crisi creato in vista dell'imminente
fine legislatura questo fondo prevede lo
stanziamento di 134 miliardi di euro
allora quali siamo anche qui non occorre
fare tanti i conti per capire una
manovra più o meno una ventina di
miliardi di euro
siamo
una manovra pesante sui 20 30 miliardi
di euro passiamo a manovre spaventose e
quindi già questo ti fa capire che una
bufala oltre alle cose precedenti che
non troveranno lavoro nell'anno
successivo per i parlamentari che
dovevano lavoro nel successivo alla fine
e questo quando in italia i malati di
sla sono costretti a pagarsi da sole le
cure rifletti se fai girare ecco allora
l'unica cosa di cui uno probabilmente
ovviamente pone l'attenzione sono le
ultime tre righe è quella in cui si
parla dei malati di sla
quindi attenzione forte verso il
l'emotività totale disinteresse per la
realtà della notizia questa qui
veramente lo dico adesso la vedete
l'avrete vista se qualcuno di voi
sicuramente la vista
anzi possiamo così chi l'ha vista questa
notizia ecco perfetto fate line
ok però è un concetto chiaro cioè è
sicuramente adesso chi non l'ha mai
vista a caso il prossimo anno la verità
ancora sarà ancora il senatore ci venga
saranno sempre 134 milioni di euro e
saranno sempre 257 più 165 più dei
senatori della repubblica italiana
sempre uguale se proprio non cambia idea
che il format così è e così che manda
allora la domanda è ma possiamo credere
che esista detto che questa è la
stupidità dei greci e possiamo credere
che esista una intelligenza della folla
possiamo crederlo possiamo crederlo
abbiamo anche delle realtà inoppugnabili
concrete che ce lo fermano e vedremo
anche se tra la platea
mantenete il concetto di intelligenza
della folla perché 100 persone di voi
hanno fatto questo esperimento che mi
interessa adesso condividere con voi con
le video con voi in diretta i risultati
e vediamo se siamo stati se siete stati
bravi o povero perché perché il concetto
di intelligenza della folla nasce più di
cento anni fa la persona che vedete gli
e thomas galton in un centinaio un
centinaio di anni fa anche più 120 anni
fa ad una fiera campionaria
vide che c'era una riffa in cui le
persone erano invitate a scommettere
quanto sarebbe pesato un animale come
quello pesato e disossato 800 persone
parteciparono alla leaf è una persona e
appunto si avvicinò di più il più
possibile risultato e vinse il premio
thomas che altro si fece dare gli 800
bigliettini delle persone che avevano
partecipato alla leaf e scoprire una
cosa sconvolgente
mentre alcune persone avevano detto che
pesava una follia e altre che pesavano
pochissimo la media delle persone era
assolutamente vicina con un errore del 5
per cento al real peso dell'animale
pesato disossato questo è quello a cui
il risultato come vocal ton ea partire
da quel momento sono scoccate tutta una
serie di studi di approfondimenti
metodologici tecnici eccetera per
cercare di sviluppare quello che veniva
definito allora come adesso
l'intelligenza della folla è la
cosiddetta guida lockout che un libro
del 2004 ma è tradotto in italiano
a chi ha partecipato al gioco e qui e
questa e l'urna dopo i risultati nel
diretta allora vi dico solamente che di
questa di tutto questo qui qualcuno ha
dichiarato che se queste sono mezze
penne rigate è più o meno mezzo chilo di
mezze penne rigate medico soli a chi sa
ho partecipato a questo gioco qualcuno
ha detto che qui ce ne sono mille e
ottocento una persona ha detto il valore
più basso ha detto che se ne sono 70
all'ora
il risultato finale l'ha inventato reale
di 287 la media che è stata raggiunta da
voi è di 200 e 72
l'errore è più o meno pari al 5 per
cento
e chi ha vinto ha fatto un risultato
minore della media perché la persona che
si è avvicinato di più ha detto che ce
n'erano 300 quindi il concetto è che in
questo caso anche in questo caso come
nel caso di altro siamo riusciti
voi siete riusciti attraverso delle
stime indipendenti in cui si accolgono
sia quella è proprio più assurde in
assoluto che quelle in sia in altezza
che in ribasso la media visto che gli ha
posto i sensi si eliminano ha permesso
di arrivare al risultato molto molto
vicino alla realtà questa è
l'intelligenza della folla che di cui di
cui tom hall galton è stato il percorso
noi continuiamo qualcuno si era accorto
che stavamo parlando del di raffaella
carrà dei fagioli e delle delle varie
esperienze che sono state fatte nel
belle
e passato in tv eccetera però voglio
aggiungere anche alcune cose ad esempio
a parte appunto riselli bean che sono
quelli che abbiamo visto adesso c'è
anche un altro esempio empirico molto
interessante che quello che nasce dalla
trasmissione chi vuol essere milionario
ve la ricorderete tutti c'erano tre
possibilità di risposta 1 rispondeva lui
o rispondeva l'amico da casa oppure
rispondeva il pubblico presente in sala
le statistiche alla fine quando è stato
chiuso il programma ci danno chiaramente
un enorme vantaggio nella capacità
predittiva del pubblico in studio
rispetto alla persona da casa sono più o
meno 20 punti percentuali di differenza
quindi anche questo ci conferma che il
le previsioni che vengono fatte da una
folla possono essere molto migliori
delle previsioni che vengono fatte dal
singolo però naturalmente ci sono delle
caratteristiche che devono essere
rispettate e nel corso del tempo abbiamo
anche implementato dei delle tecniche
delle mitologie molto sofisticate che si
hanno permesso di arrivare a dei
risultati molto molto interessanti ve ne
condivido 1 nel 2008
attraverso uno strumento di prediction
market che sfrutta e il tema
dell'intelligenza collettiva di cui
parlerò adesso nel 2008 come vedete il
nate silver un americano molto molto
preparatore nei confronti di questi temi
predittivi ebbe un risultato
strabiliante
come potete vedere poter prevedere dc
dei 50 stati presenti negli stati uniti
ebbe una perfetta della previsione
corretta su 49 stati quindi ne sbaglia
uno solo questo è un esempio clamoroso
della capacità dei pardi con market di
essere e robusto e assolutamente
affidabile per vision market che sfrutta
questi termini di intelligenza
collettiva viene usato un po in tutti
gli ambiti professionali pubblici
attuali per noi lo usiamo moltissimo per
fare le previsioni politiche ma viene
utilizzato anche è stato utilizzato
anche dal governo americano per sul
cambiamento climatico è stato usato
durante la guerra del golfo è stato
usato in per stabilire i prezzi
dell'ipad mini per esempio viene usato
dal packard per stabilire i i bilanci
provvisori nel corso dell'anno
intervistando i quadri quindi è uno
strumento che viene utilizzato
moltissimo e che ha delle grandi
capacità di previsione purché venga
utilizzato appunto con un vegano salis
come si dice si sono appunto delle
regole molto precise perché predicano
market possa essere utilizzato e sono e
sono il fatto che deve essere garantita
la diversità di opinione come è capitato
a voi che avete appunto
indipendentemente dagli altri deciso
quanti quanti mezze penne ci sono qua
dentro le vostre opinioni non devono
essere appunto come vedete influenzate
da quelli degli altri
nessuno deve avere il privilegio
rispetto agli altri di decidere lite
cosa stiamo parlando o quali sono le
previsioni definitive le opinioni poi
devono essere devono poter essere creata
in modo da ottenere un risultato finale
e soprattutto appunto alla fine di tutto
un gruppo scelto a caso risolutori di
problemi e questa è la
la regola fondamentale se rispettiamo le
presse
questo è l'esito fondamentale se
rispettiamo le regole precedenti un
gruppo scelto a caso risolutori di
problemi dai risultati migliori del
gruppo dei migliori sono tour
individuali grazie